The shock has been felt around the world.
Flowers and notes turned up outside the US embassy in Moscow.
From South Africa, an expression of solidarity.
We take strong exception to instances where people or groups...
...resort to violence to settle whatever their difference.
And one from China as well.
China strongly condemns and opposes all violent attacks against civilians,...
...and feels grieved about those killed in the incident.
From Afghanistan, which has had more than its share of bombings,...
...came condolences from President Hamid Karzai through his deputy spokesman.
He was saddened to hear that innocent people were hurt.
The people of Afghanistan can very well understand better than any other country in the world...
...the suffering and the pains that arise from such incidents.
In Berlin, German Foreign Minister Guido Westerwelle...
...expressed what has been on the minds of many in Boston and across the US.
What was intended as a great event of joy turned into a terrible tragedy.
I hope that the perpetrators of this cruel act will be found and brought to justice.
London is set to hold its own marathon in days.
Boris Johnson is London's mayor.
The events in Boston were absolutely horrific...
...and obviously our thoughts are with the victims and their families.
Johnson says security in London will be stepped up and that the race will go on.
For now, going on is all that many affected by the Boston Marathon bombings can do.
Jeff Seldin, VOA News.